et je rappelle autre chose il y à un
article dans la loi sur la presse qui
prévoit une peine de quinze mille euros
d'amendé pour quiconque diffuse l'image
d'une personne menottée
alors qu'elle n'a pas encore été
condamnés souvenons nous par exemple de
la sphère dominique strauss kahn
oui où on voyait son image sur les
chaînes de télévision évidemment il
n'était pas dans une position lui
permettait de porter plainte sur menotté
il aurait pu porter plainte et faire
condamner les chaînes de télévision
quinze mille euros d'amande et qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans cette affaire parce
qu'on parlait tout à l'heure de
présomption d'innocence
rappelons le dans cette affaire la
plainte de la partie civile de la
plaignante a été classée sans suite et
dominique strauss kahn n'a pas été jugé
dans cette affaire mais au-delà de
l'aspect juridique moi je trouve que
tout l'aspect moral on a décidé de ne
plus diffuser la tête des terroristes
parce que ce sont des monstres et qu'on
n'a pas envie de les mettre en héros et
comme danser ça certains endroits
j'appelle pas ça des jeunes mais ces
délinquants et ont déjà la haine du flic
donc montrer le visage de cette personne
c'est trop d'honneur à lui faire et
j'estime que justement on n'a pas à elle
montrer parce que c'est pas un héros
d'avoir tué un flic et personne à beaune
en noir ce visage je suis d'accord avec
quasiment personne sur ce plateau tout
simplement parce que je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on couvre toujours les
délinquants pourquoi on devrait faire
des pincettes avec eux pourquoi pouvoir
montrer leur visage
il ya des personnes qui l'ont du même
son collègue ali ben qui a vingt la vue
a confirmé claude roy pourquoi ne pas le
montrer par adam co2 combien d'années
d'études de droit de formation
bénéficier pour dire aujourd'hui que
vous allez rendre la justice sur un
plateau que j'étais trop lynx si je ne
vous permets pas un policier qui nous
est fermé ça madame
je ne vous permet pas de dire que
réussie des gens qui seraient
complaisant avec des auteurs d'actes
aussi atroces que celui-ci oui pas vrai
oui non madame si madame ce n'est pas
vrai moi je suis gêné dans l'île puisque
vous d'ailleurs moi je n'agis pas comme
un retour comme vous le faites avec une
affaire comme celle-ci d'accord je
n'agis pas comme un vautour qui va sur
des corps encore chaud les prendre dans
le bec pour aller les acheter sur le
plateau de télévision tbs mois gratuits
dont la république terrain claude la
république c'est la musique il y en a
qui se bat jamais vu que cela juste à
iliad et l'agility suédois elle doit
l'être désiré vous êtes un gîte à la
justice
elle doit agir avec sérénité c'est la
condition pour que la justice soit
respectée puisque rien que je suis ravi
de voir que vous venez de série multi
parce que vous faites quelques vidéos et
que vous diffusez des théories de
l'extrême droite à longueur de journée
vous êtes plus habilité qu'un magistrat
qu'un policier qu'un avocat a traité du
registre fils sacha se plonger dans les
cimes
les victimes elles attendent elles
souffrent c'est toujours les personnes
qui sont les bourreaux qui change en
quoi une photo une photo à la télévision
d'un suspect il a des centaines de
familles des victimes pour lesquelles
souffrent eux mangent abus on vient
peut-être que si les parents à éduquer
et du curé de leurs enfants et le
cerveau ne se retrouverait pas sur bfm
tv d'accord je pense que tu le rapport
le rapport c'est que quand même une
photo d'une personne qui a fait un crime
moi je suis désolé il assez pas les
suspects et oui mais à un moment donné
faut arrêter il ya des personnages en
répondent et sa dame madame s'il vous
plaît pour les justes
s'il vous plaît quelques lauriers
assassine un policier s'est pas
dissuasif excusez moi un acte horrible
c'est vrai ça madame madame j'ai une
question à vous poser dans 48 heures on
le relâche parce que c'est pas lui c'est
qu'on attendait il y a des preuves
non mais on n'est pas juste après le
même sens admettons admettons
présomption d'innocence ce n'est
peut-être pas lui pourquoi dans ce pays
on ne peut jamais rien faire masse qui
me ce qui me scandalise est installé on
ne peut jamais rien montré
on ne peut jamais bien de dire si j'ai
pas lu je suis désolé il un passif il a
un pénis ne voyait un passif il a commis
des agressions
il était dans du trafic de drogue il un
passif il ya le policier qui vous dit
qu'il était coupable idéal où il y à
vélo son ami
aux jeunes il est ce qu'il a confirmé je
veux dire un moment donné quand il ya
des personnes qui sont en danger
pourquoi ne peut pas mettre un d agilité
sur moi